we were we were at a 24-hour fitness and
we were playing ball it was on a fast
break I had the ball this dude comes up
and on the fast break
I grab they pass to me I grab the ball
and as about to turn around this guy
steps on my foot shoulder checks me
sends me [ __ ] flying dude and I got
so mad I turned around I started
stocking the wall behind us because I
just went red no so pissed and I [ __ ]
Chuck the ball on awhile stopping over
to the guy
and Jesus said Jason cracked up because
I didn't realize this at the time but I
was so angry but as I'm not the sokka's
dude in his face he goes I'm so sorry
minute and my sock turned into a hug
it's all good it's all good man and I
just cool down super fast and Jason was
cracking up lastly your kryptonite is
apologies apologies like genuine apology
cuz think about it if if in that moment
after he shoulder checks me I come up
and I sock him in his face after he
apologizes how big of an [ __ ] am i
I'm the biggest [ __ ] I've been
attacked because I've apologized really
cuz they sense weakness oh yeah [ __ ]
what dick that's jump on I was in high
school but I was like what's his name
you Joe mama back then oh no no it was
Dallas junior high but I forgot what it
was but then I started to smell that
people will fight they would they would
actually attack you harder because now
they know they can [ __ ] you up oh it
gives him confidence that's a bad person
yeah that's a bad person
it was so prevalent like back in the day
yeah guy was he said sorry in the most
nicest way possible Eagles dude I'm so
sorry I went home I started seeing
Christian hens right after you stepped
out but he but I remember Jason was
cracking up after that and then [ __ ]
Joseph Vince I think he avoided me for
like a month because he got freaked out
yeah can I don't think he's used to like
violence well dude if I just saw a
random person just start punching a wall
and all the stories that you tell me
where you get really upset the common
theme is is that you get so crazy and
you start punching walls because when I
was in looking so let me explain that
[ __ ] for a second which is fine you know
punch walls I punched pillows so when I
went when I was a kid and just saved
those [ __ ]
this is like elementary school [ __ ]
right so I had to go through like school
therapy because I had anger problems
just growing up as a kid my house is
pretty violent so I was very violent and
I didn't know how to control my anger
and I got removed from my elementary
school from fighting too much I almost
got removed from the second elementary
school that I went to and it was because
I would always start throwing fists and
the main reason why it's good I just get
bullied but my dad would tell me hey if
you're gonna get bullied or if
somebody's gonna try to bully you better
make sure that you're the most difficult
person to bully so I would just start
fighting back and if I'm the guy that's
not gonna take your [ __ ] you're gonna
find somebody else to bully instead of
me and that's what would happen so but
because of that violence became an
answer for everything so when I hit
junior high I tried to calm down a bit
but I had this [ __ ] pent-up anger so
the only thing I could do is that
hitting somebody was punch other things
yeah so ended up being a bad habit so
every time I got angry instead of just
are swinging at people I would just saw
things and I remember the first time
that I got caught in school punching
[ __ ] it was like this water fountain I
was drinking water and I got so [ __ ]
angry because I got sent outside I just
want to go drink some what I started
pounding my fist into the [ __ ]
fountain and then my hand just swelled
the [ __ ] up and had to go home because I
couldn't use my hand oh Jesus Christ
David so yeah and so you could see this
hand this hands all [ __ ] up too
because I always use my right hand and I
switch it to the left like an idiot
hands all I can't I can't do this so if
I got one two three four five one two
three these two go up together
right hand is battle-tested
battle-hardened this [ __ ] hurts well it
I can't I can't bring these up
separately they have to come up together
so I don't know what happened but I know
I had a fracture I fractured this in
college from parts a barroom fracture
well in so this is the the weird college
story was that when I was in college
this is when I was trying to you know
just really better myself as a human
being but punch the wall instead lame so
there was this girl named Nellie she was
in my dorm and in college there's this
you know when you take a math class and
then you have the thing afterwards I
forgot what it's called it's it's so you
have the lecture in the workshop
so there was this kid who I think he was
like a bully in high school or some [ __ ]
but the way he was kind of carrying
himself he was carrying himself like an
[ __ ] yeah here's too-cool-for-school
yeah so nelly this is before the the TA
came in and he was gonna go over the
material but nelly he was hitting on
Nelly Nelly was [ __ ] find his [ __ ]
form I remember she was [ __ ] cute
she's like this Middle Eastern girl and
this dude was hitting on her and she
wasn't really having it and he was she
was like telling him to leave it alone
I'm not really interested and then he
just started like harassing her and I
mind you I'm like this dweeby kid
classes and whatever but I'm a big guy
and I'm like Amen just leave her alone
right and then this guy I don't know if
he got embarrassed or he felt a little
weird about it but as I was sitting down
on my at my desk this fool he was
sitting in front of me he turns his desk
around faces me and he goes well now
you're gonna be my best friend I
remember that line he goes you're gonna
be my best friend too [ __ ] lame and I
you know like when people say that [ __ ]
you kind of don't know what to say I was
like he went to like Saved by the Bell
High School's there yeah he's the righty
kid so number one I never grew up with
this type of [ __ ] right so you know
growing up what was he oh why is it what
guy oh [ __ ] that kind of bullying is
like I will slap you across the face
[ __ ] yeah and so immediately I just so
he's like this white boy and it comes up
and he goes now we're gonna be best
friends and I'm like punish like
confused Oh does that mean what the [ __ ]
does that mean and I'm sitting there
kind of confused that's the guy from The
Breakfast Club and then I just look at
the dude and I go I need you to move
away from me right and he goes like no
man we're best friends now and he's
sitting there just leaning over on the
desk like smiling at me pompous and the
smiling makes me angrier and angrier so
I just get up and there's like a wall
next to me I just started slamming my
[ __ ] fist into it and it's it was a
wall I remember it was plaster that was
plastic and then plaster and then there
was like a beam behind it and I didn't I
didn't know there was a beam there so I
just cracked the wall until I hit the
beam and when I ripped it out there was
blood just gushing out for my [ __ ]
hand and I sat down and I just kept
staring at him and the guy got his [ __ ]
any left
oh yeah and then so this this was
actually during Halloween weekend and so
I was bleeding all over the place I
thought it was like prosthetics or some
[ __ ] know what so this is what happened
I was bleeding and when I was walking
out the class I guess I left like this
trail of blood and I the the TA was
asking who the [ __ ] you know put the
hole in the wall and all this other [ __ ]
but nobody said anything they didn't rat
me out thank [ __ ] god but when I went
back to the to the UH to my dorm the TA
looked at my hand and started laughing
because he thought it was a Halloween
prank oh my god but that's I think
that's when I fractured these two things
here to prove that point I know I didn't
that's a dope way to do it though
honestly really I thought I have a mic
[ __ ] or punched him in his [ __ ] cuz
that dude he's he's never gonna look at
you the same way never came back to that
class he dropped out of that class yeah
you traumatized him he was such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude like what kind of
what kind of dude you that's true cuz if
you hit him he would have probably sued
oh for sure he's my only one or don't
[ __ ] share or to suit you I should have
sucked you're such a good Christian dude
I know dude I didn't punch that guy I
was wrong about you David so thank you
man I try to be the best human being
that I can be and you know when I look
back at that type of I don't have that
type of anger anymore right just flip
out and start punching [ __ ] anymore but
just there's not a little bit of that
living is depends if Muriel does it to
me see a lot of mine came back when I
started fighting in relationship well
because they're the only ones that can
take us there
yeah I thought it was not there anymore
and I thought I was fine until we start
arguing
it's then the walls start getting oh
it's like Oh post-apocalyptic look you
know I'm going for that [ __ ] Book of
Eli look good I just gotta get a pillow
and just be like just scream right into
it every time you [ __ ] get super
pissed I've been managing my anger much
better now that's good yeah how do you
do it I feel it out instead of thinking
it out so if I feel it and I notice that
it's there I move it down and then I let
it melt in and it's just a feeling
because I kept trying to think it out
and then I got better and better at it
by so you sorry accepting
yeah well like just just recognizing
that the feeling needs to go like I
think sparring and fighting and and all
those things just helped me because I
can't think clear and I get more
frustrated when I'm doing that exercise
well like well it's not it's like it's
like if you can overcome over like
dealing with irritation and fear during
sparring or something like that right
and then it's like cuz you have to do
that in order to think clearer yeah you
got to use that for the same situation
so if I am in that moment and I'm
ruminating over thoughts and I'm like
okay stop thinking because all the words
that are coming out of your head is
gonna be bad
yeah and it's gonna drive you to that
point and you just gotta like melt into
what you do and try to drive that energy
downwards and in common dammed yeah
that's like it's hard do it it's [ __ ]
hard I didn't know that that was you can
do that but I do that for when I'm
fighting cuz sometimes you just gotta
like yeah take the hits you gotta
embrace it and you when you feel
yourself panic I'm sure like you're very
you know what what this is all about but
like I just thought of recognizing like
oh [ __ ] I'm actually panicking when I
didn't know that I was panicking and it
might not show it but then it's like not
helping me in my game and I have to just
kind of like figure out how to be there
yeah that's just hard I feel like my
anger now comes from more frustration
that it comes from like some kind of
external external yeah it's internal
like it's like you can't figure
something out so then you get mad or
something yeah I get frustrated and
turns into anger yeah and I think I get
upset at myself because it's super
childish it's very Daddy it's very very
[ __ ] petty it's being like a road rage
yeah I have road rage and I'm [ __ ]
shut that [ __ ] down cuz I dangerous
you're good enough you're gonna hurt
people on a row man no I really I just
get really frustrated with certain
people that are just careless
like if somebody I got I've been in the
car before and if somebody almost hits
us like it's really [ __ ] close I see
like red I get really upset do you look
at the driver and you oh they're just
old it's okay no you know what sometimes
but it's just like I just need them to
acknowledge
kind of what you talked about yes I just
need them to just be like yo I [ __ ] up
because in my head I'm like a couple
inches away you I could have died
especially because he drove me on it
yeah it'd have died I drove a small like
[ __ ] tiny car [ __ ] that car by the way
yeah yeah it's it's done with I I don't
know I feel like the road is just like a
danger zone yeah so [ __ ] happens I'm
like alright whatever that's just a
stroke of luck right yeah but what gives
me road rage is people that try to be
tough in their car I that's another
thing that's another thing I was about
to go meet this guy in Hawaii and we're
going to the airport and I was in the
car with my girl and then this guy just
honking behind me right and then he
drives up and he rolls down his window
and I'm thinking oh [ __ ] he needs help
or something something like what's going
on and he's like why don't you learn how
to drive he tells me yeah and then I
look at him and I [ __ ] you not the first
thing is pull the [ __ ] over
we're gonna [ __ ] fight [ __ ]
and he just looks at me like this
see and then he tried he slow like I'm
trying to be like faith like drive next
to him like that
yeah I'm yelling and then like the the
light turns green right I'm just like
trying to match my speed with him so so
he doesn't try to stop and I'm like go
go we're pulling over just [ __ ] pull
over like I'm not gonna have a
conversation with you yeah and then this
will just completely stops while the
road is all going yeah and then he goes
behind me and he [ __ ] makes a right
see that's the thing it's like if there
wasn't this barrier yeah you would never
talk to another human being like that
yeah I mean in a certain point you're
like why would you even confront someone
if you're not gonna do something to them
aggressively and insult them if you're
not ready to die yeah if you don't have
that same energy right yeah cuz I don't
know when I always think like if I'm
ready to confront someone and give them
that kind of energy I'm ready to die
yeah yeah
like cuz you don't know if that person
is armed you don't know if they're crazy
you don't know they have a knife you
don't know even in a fist fight things
in accidents can happen
we're like they could get a lucky sucker
punch but your head goes down and I know
someone that died this way she was at a
party
then she got into a fight and in her hit
her head hit the curb she had a brain
what do you call it an impression and
here's them and then she died yeah ain't
so like a very common actually it's not
like that [ __ ] happens all the time
I mean he was an older middle-aged white
guy so so to me I'm like okay I gotta
remember they all they they work in a
different world you know they could yell
and be aggressive yeah but they don't
they don't get into violence because
that's against the law they